what's up guys Sean here Sam is driving
for some Memorial Day weekend thing so
it's just me flying solo today but got
some good stuff to talk about first it's
been almost exactly a year since I had
this idea for the podcast so I'm looking
at my messages right now too Sam so 5:13
2019 so this is May 13th a year ago I
messaged him you know I got a
proposition for you he says yes I said
I'm starting a podcast it's like how I
built this good quality good guess and I
sent him a list of guests that I had in
mind and I said I want the hustle to be
the publisher I'll do all the work you
included in the email and there's in
your episode if we start monetizing
let's share the economics Sam says okay
deal I said cool I'll send you the first
episode to preview at the end of this
week and then we go back and forth a
little bit and then and then we started
you know I you know the first thing I
did was I went and found somebody who
could edit a podcast by going on Twitter
and writing podcast editor in the search
and I'm looking for people who wrote
that in their bio and then I found a
Sean who was an editor for other
people's podcasts we made a cover or we
made we figured out a name if I'm
looking in the messages here the
original name that I was thinking was
because I was basing it off of how I
built this so the name was how I got
rich which I decided was way too you
know an accrued or something it could've
been good name it's at least sort of I
don't know get your attention but but I
knew I'd have trouble getting guests on
with that name and in fact my first
million also had trouble getting guests
on because a lot of people who were
successful don't want to come talk about
money and they don't want to seem like a
rich but it worked out anyways
my first millions got off the ground we
shifted off of interviews and started
doing more casual brainstorm type
episodes and that's what people
resonated with they liked listening to
something where you know it gets the
wheels turning in your head it gets you
to learn about a new space or a new
business model or a new product that you
hadn't heard of and people like to hear
two people scheming and thinking up you
know new ideas and dreaming about what
what could be because there's not very
many podcasts to do that and so that's
what I learned along the way I'm looking
at our stats now
we have reached over 2 million downloads
so we did about a million downloads in
the first six months and a little more
than that and then the let the second
half and dude I could have never
imagined that we would hit 2 million
downloads in year 1 that's kind of
amazing I'm like in shock even right now
just sort of looking at it because I
don't really check you know I don't
really pay too much attention to it
because I'm not doing this really for
the listeners in fact when I started
this I told Sam I said he asked me why
are you doing this and I said well our
company's getting acquired we're it's
we're in the due diligence phase right
now and it's a lot of either lawyers or
security people looking at our code
things like that like it's really boring
I want to do something I can't start a
company but I can start a podcast during
this time and so I need I had the itch
to start something and this was my
something and I'd always wanted to do a
podcast because I like to talk and I
figured this would just be a great
little networking hack you know when I
actually started the podcast I didn't
think anybody would listen to it
my plan was there's all these
interesting people here in San Francisco
I want to meet him instead of just
saying hey my name is Shawn I'm a
founder and this company you want to get
some coffee
which is annoying I hate when people ask
me hey can I have some of your time you
want to get a coffee do you want to do a
call we'd love to chat I'm like what's
in it for me
this is awful I don't want to I don't
even drink coffee so that but if
somebody invites me on a podcast or
advise me to speak at a conference I'm
like okay cool tell me more
and I usually say yes and it's weird
because it doesn't matter how many
people are listening to the podcast or
it could be an event that has a hundred
people but still it feels good to sort
of be on stage and I knew that other
people like that too so my goal was this
is a great way to meet interesting
people and have an excuse to connect
with them and I thought nobody will
listen to this except for my mom but
I'll build a cool network of people
through the podcast that was my my evil
plan and then I got greedy once it
started growing and now it's now I
kicked off all that yes and now it's
just me and Sam talking but yeah my
perspective change I think that's a good
lesson too in general so I had one
decisive reason to do it
which was this will be a great way to
meet other cool people I got that out of
it and I did you know 30 episodes with
different guests we've built awesome
companies and then you know I discovered
a different opportunity as I was doing
it which was hey a lot of people
actually listening to this ok instead of
making this about meeting the guess what
if I made this about giving the audience
content that they like and being you
know being somebody that they listen to
on a regular basis and I've you know
sort of pivoted pivoted from there but
anyways it's been amazing one year one
year since having the idea and that's
that's pretty bizarre I think I'll
probably be podcasting for like ten
years that's my guess because I like
this a lot
and I mr. cool there's all these
different things that have come from it
and I think you know if you're somebody
out there who doesn't create content
today it is where I would start if I was
somebody who wants to have a
non-traditional career if you don't want
to just have a job or hell even if you
want a job but you just want a better
job this is what I would do right off
the bat I would start creating content
about a topic I like either interviewing
guests and networking that way or
talking about a subject researching and
talking about a subject that you're
interested in learning more about and
just publishing and just publishing
regularly because you'd be surprised who
listens pretty badass people who saw
this podcast and they reach out and then
opportunities come my way or investments
come my way or whatever it builds trust
in people and the beauty of it is that
it's low effort right I record once for
one hour but each episode gets listened
to for thousands and thousands of hours
by other people so you know my one hour
yields tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of listen to hours and that's
amazing leverage right I'm getting a
multiplier of let's call it a hundred
thousand to one on my effort and time
which is kind of amazing that's why I
would produce content and I would it
also forces you to think about content
as a product right so you got to make
content that people want you got to
figure out how to distribute it to them
you're gonna figure out how to monetize
it so it's a great little mini business
in and of itself without any cost really
you just gotta you know buy a microphone
that's kind of the extent of it it's not
much more beyond that anyways I wanted
to because I'm flying solo today I
wanted to actually look back and look at
some of the different ideas that we've
bring
stormed and I want to give you my top
ten half-baked business ideas that we've
talked about on the podcast so as we've
been riffing and brainstorming and just
kind of shooting the these are my
10 favorite ideas that we've talked
about podcasts I don't know if they're
the best ten ideas they're my favorites
which means I find them interesting
either because I think they would work
or I think there's a nugget of something
interesting there and if somebody really
kind of remixed it or rift on it or sort
of built it up fleshed it out they could
build a great business around it so I'll
give you my top 10 and this will be kind
of a recap episode we'll keep it short
all right so number one or actually
start at number 10 number 10 first dibs
okay what's first dibs okay so this is
when we were looking at auction houses
we were breaking down
I think heritage auctions which did
eight hundred fifty million dollars last
year in auctions which just shocked me
right people selling collectible coins
movie posters comic books I had no idea
collectibles and auctions are as popular
as they were I knew they were a thing
but I didn't realize how much money was
really flowing through that system and
so anytime I observe something that
surprises me I want to know more and I
see that as an opportunity I used to see
something odd and be like that's weird
move in the other direction and now when
I see something that might that's weird
tell me everything there is to know
about this and I'll give you an example
I remember when I was in college this
guy who lived on our whole tewfiq
probably the strangest guy I've ever met
I walked into his room his dorm room and
he was looking at his computer and he
was look at he's playing a video game I
was like oh what are you playing an
eternity he looked at me and the game
kept going like his character kept
moving and I'll say whoa you're not even
touching the mouse house is happening
he's like oh I'm not playing I'm
watching as you're watching a video game
is you know back in 2001 2006 2007
something like that and he's like yeah
yeah this is a replay of a Starcraft you
know tournament that happened yesterday
those are what I was like you watch
other people like video games and he
said yeah it's great I'm like and it
wasn't even live it was a recording of a
Korean match that some guy had
commentated over record and post on the
internet and he was catching up first
thing in the morning he woke up and he
was watching it
I was like this is so weird you're so
weird dude I moved on with my life now
fast forward you know 10-15 years later
I sell my company to twitch which is the
largest live game streaming you know a
place to go watch other people in video
games you know who knew but he knew and
he knew it was awesome and if at that
time I had been like whoa this is
interesting why do you do this I could
have learned a lot more I could have
started twitch had I really sniffed out
that opportunity and instead you know
now I work at twitch and you know
they've created a multi-billion dollar
company out of it
sounds like kind of learning for me
anyways back to first dibs so as I was
looking at these auction auction houses
you know of course you have eBay which
is the auction site for everything but
then I saw all these niche ones there's
goat for sneakers you know for sneaker
heads bring a trailer is an auction site
for vintage cars and it seems like you
know on the surface that there's every
every niches cover there's an auction
site for everything so what do you do
when there's no inventory left there's
nothing else there's no there's no niche
left you got to make a new niche you got
to make something make a new inventory
that doesn't even exist yet so the idea
for first dibs is it's an auction house
for things that don't exist yet now what
does that mean you would partner with
musicians artists movie studios athletes
and you would auction off their first
whatever you know these are the first
hundred of this new line of LeBron
sneakers that are coming out so it's the
same sneaker that's gonna go for sale
but auctioning off the first hundred to
be made the first hundred Tesla Model 3
s the first hundred t-shirts the first
hundred of copies of this album from
your favorite musician I think people
would pay a premium maybe even a super
premium for getting first dibs from the
creators that they love musicians
athletes artists movie studios etc and
it's like cool kids version of
Kickstarter right if you're a famous
musician you're not gonna do a
Kickstarter it's sort of beneath you
like a cool version of doing the same
thing you're gonna say hey we're gonna
make an album if you want to have one of
the first hundred copies or you want to
be the first 1,000 people to listen to
the single you can pay me right now you
know $500 piece to get that and you
would end up raising you know
potentially half a million dollars up
front to fund your project just they're
selling first dibs to your superfans
alright that's that idea number nine
drone light shows
so fireworks big industry but there's
all kinds of problems sound pollution
air pollution danger so this is a new
way of doing fireworks you do it with a
fleet of drones that are all
synchronized I'll have lights on top of
them so you've probably seen this you
know intel is doing a bunch of these
demos for new year some people do this
but I think there's an opportunity to do
this at a franchise level on the local
and local markets so fireworks you know
pretty big business to two billion
dollars a year in a last year I think
you can do that with drones I think you
can basically say hey you know pay a
thousand dollars you're gonna have a
drone light show at your corporate
retreat at your birthday party at your
cities you know festival or whatever it
is and so it's a business in a box and
if somebody was to create a drone light
show franchise I bet you could have
franchisees in you know 100 cities in
the next two years if you if you've made
it easy for them to push a button and
have their own drone light show business
all right
number eight just talking all right
there's one of my favorite ideas I was
talking to my uncle who was divorced
he's you know 60 years old and he's
lonely you know like he's not lonely in
a depressed way but like it's just a
reality situation how would you feel if
you were six years old and you're
divorced and your kids have grown up and
they moved out of the house and a lot of
people tell them you know you should get
out there you should go and do also do
online dating but you know that's normal
for Millennials but for somebody like my
uncle that's kind of intimidating he
doesn't necessarily want to go put
himself out there and he doesn't even
necessarily want to you know start
dating and remarry somebody that's not
his goal and so I think you can create
something that is just talking it's a
way for people to connect it's for way
for sort of single people to connect but
not for dating and so it gives you know
the baby boomer generation a way to go
online and just chat in a safe place
it's sort of like you know you've seen
the oldies Netflix shows love is blind
or the circle and you know I think
they're tapping into something which is
that you can form a pretty strong bond
with somebody just by talking and I
think you could build a subscription
business around giving seniors and baby
boomers a place where they can go push a
button and have somebody to talk to
all right this episode is brought to you
by Super side all right so here's the
deal I'm incredibly impatient like
horribly horribly impatient and if I get
an idea at midnight by 8 a.m. the next
day I want it done you know but that's
really hard because if something needs
to be designed where am I gonna find a
designer at midnight to try to make this
thing get brain to life so you know I
don't Lee I'm alone other startups even
huge companies need design help fast
and they just don't have the internal
resources or expertise to get it done so
how do you get reliable design done
without dealing with expensive agencies
and lots of freelancers you use super
side that's our sponsor for this week
just go to super site calm slash MFM and
tell them what you want they have a team
of designers that can get it done fast
you know they are 20 times faster than
hiring a designer and 50% more
affordable than a traditional agency so
if you need high quality design done
fast try super side lots of fast growing
teams that are stretched or using them
already check them out super sicom slash
MFM I'm using before I love them check
it out alright number 7 is YC for
content okay so first you got to know
what YC is YC is y combinator it's the
sort of best startup accelerator that's
ever been built
they incubated or not incubated really
but they accelerated companies like
Airbnb Dropbox etc etc bunch of
billion-dollar companies so they're
super successful and what they did was
they said hey we can take two people
with an idea and we can in three months
give them a clear focus which says hey
at the end of these three months you're
gonna be on stage in front of a group of
investors who want to invest in you and
you got to have a great product and
you're gonna have traction you gotta
have something to show for yourself
something you've done in these three
months that will give them the
confidence to invest in your your
company and through office hours whatnot
they hit they made that happen
and so they can help to create a whole
bunch more startups that otherwise
wouldn't been created they helped get
them funded so I believe we're in the
biggest boom ever for content content is
king in a way that it hasn't been before
you have Netflix if Disney Plus Hulu HBO
Apple TV Plus quippy you have all these
companies that are spending billions as
a capital B billions into original
content they these are platforms that
are hungry for content they're walking
in
Benihana's they're looking for sizzling
content on the grill
so I think you can create Y Combinator
for content it's an accelerator where
you take talented people who are either
directors showrunners producers whatever
and they create a pitch for the show and
at the end you have a demo day where
they're gonna invest in funding your
pilot and so you can create a sizzle
reel which is like a two minute trailer
essentially for your show that's what
you create during the three months and
you come in and you say hey here's the
concept
it's a group of friends that get lost on
this island but then they discover you
know mysteries that that start you know
when they when they dig up this hole and
it's like oh yeah wave it's that lost
yeah it's kind of like lost but it's the
new waves lost so anyways you the idea Y
Combinator for content I think someone
should go to LA start this now if you're
willing to do this I would love to be
involved ok I'm going to zip through a
few more quickly so Boy Scouts without
the religion and sexual harassment so
this happened when me and Sam
brainstormed about Boy Scouts big
business two million members two hundred
million dollars plus and revenue but the
recent announced earthing bankruptcy due
to all the lawsuits that they've been
slapped with so I think that the
fundamental need here is still gonna get
solved people want to have a sort of
rite of passage style program where you
learn life and nature skills and parents
want a place to put their kids you know
as sort of a glorified you know take
care work ok I don't have to watch my
kid and they're gonna learn something
they're gonna come back you know sort of
enriched in some way and so I think you
could go direct consumer through
Facebook you could have targeted ads to
parents who basically they want their
kids to stop playing fortnight and go do
something outdoors and so I think you
can create a new brand like a Boy Scouts
that's just not rooted in necessarily
religion and doesn't have the sort of
problems that Boy Scouts has had with
sexual harassment and other other things
I got them bunch of lawsuits ok great
number five org charts ok this idea came
from Daniel gross who was a special
guest on the podcast daniel was great I
should get him on again he was like you
know ten ideas a minute type of guy so
he brought up that every something that
I've noticed now that I'm at a bigger
company right I'm at a company now 2,000
people and every
company has an internal or obstruction
right as the CEO
here's their direct reports this
person's the head of marketing here's
their different reports this person does
content marketing here's their reports
and so there should be a really easy org
chart builder that can be used inside
companies say it cuz I can find hey who
who do I talk to if I'm trying to who
runs our social media I could find that
person and then secondly that should be
made public so you should be able to
look at other companies hey I'm looking
at stripe who's the head of their
developer platform and you can
crowdsource all the content by pinging
employees with each automated emails
that basis says hey we think you're the
head of this is that the right thing and
you can get people to fill it in sort of
Wikipedia style and so I think you could
use this and this could either be a free
service that you know eventually pivots
into more of a linkedin type of thing or
it could be a SAS tool for for companies
so that they can have this up there's
actually a startup they came out of
Stella step that is doing this after we
we talked about it clearly stole our
idea called the org they raised eight
million dollars from Sequoia and
founders fund and there looks like
they're doing exactly this all right
number four Hemingway for email okay I
believe that now more than ever as
companies are going remote writing is an
incredibly important skill you need to
be able to communicate through email
through slack writing memos and Google
Docs so that other people can understand
your thinking and your plans the problem
is most people suck at writing and a lot
of people are self-conscious about it
which is why a company like Graham early
can be at a hundred million dollars in
revenue just doing spell check grammar
check type of things Hemingway is a cool
little app that you know I discovered
many years ago which is it analyzes your
writing and it helps you make it more
punchy it tells you hey this paragraph
is too wordy or hey why are you using
this complicated word there's a simpler
one you could use and so I think
somebody could build a Hemingway like
tool for business and write help you
write better business emails I'm very
very interested in this I talked to the
Hemingway guys and said hey I'd like to
buy your business because I want to do
something like this so if somebody wants
to build this I'd love to help make that
happen
all right number three TRT subscription
all right so Sam has been taking TRT or
testosterone replacement therapy for a
while you know so so beverage
testosterone and a male decreases by 40%
over the last century that's
sort of I don't know how they're
measuring that because I don't think in
a hundred years they were measuring
testosterone but whatever that's a stat
it's decreased over time and when you
have a less testosterone you feel more
depressed you feel weaker you have
increased chances of heart attack blood
pressure problems etc etc you know in
normal sports you can't take
testosterone because it sort of gives
you an unfair advantage but in real life
you know there's no Commission that's
drug testing you to say hey are you
taking testosterone which helps you you
know maintain your muscularity and feel
you know sort of greater levels of
energy and whatnot I know Joe Rogan sort
of popularized this he takes
testosterone and some other things and
so here's the idea six letters d2c trt
you can make a hundred million dollars
off those six letters and yeah so you're
the direct consumer testosterone
replacement therapy solution it's a
repeat
you know recurring business every month
I think it's very high margin high
retention and potentially a big market
so I like that idea a lot I think that
could be very lucrative number two this
one's crop kitchens so this came from
Stu Stu was a guest on the podcast and
he said look food delivery is booming
GrubHub post mates ubereats they have
you know millions of users who open the
app every day and they're trying to
figure out what to eat and so now the
restaurants that are on there or just
right now your local restaurants but
what they should be is you know there
should be more diversity there should be
more special restaurants that really
they get you to click when you open up
post mates or ubereats
so cloud kitchens are on the rise which
is basically it's a central kitchen
there is no storefront there is no
in-house Dining these are kitchens
designed to produce food that gets
delivered through these apps so ubers
founder Travis Clinic he's raised I
don't know
hundreds of millions of dollars to fund
his company cloud kitchens where he's
buying real estate in cities turning
them into cloud kitchens so this one
it's clout
spelled with T at the end cloud kitchens
because it's going after influencers so
you go and you get big names in the same
way that like Gordon Ramsay Bobby Flay
Wolfgang Puck Jimmy Buffett they've
opened up their own branded restaurant
chains you could do the same thing but
on delivery only restaurants so Robert
Downey's brownies
you know ASAP rocky road the Kardashian
salad company
you know the possibilities are endless
so you have influencers they partner
with a cloud kitchen to produce one type
of cuisine and then you deliver it on
the top of all these different networks
okay I'll pick one more one more good
one here okay so this one's hooked for
romance novels so I didn't know this but
my friend taught me about this my friend
Ramon he basically educated me that
romance is one of the best-selling book
genres there is I believe it is the best
book selling genre romance fiction
really appeals to older females and one
third of all mass-market fiction books
are romance and one-third of all romance
readers are forty-five plus you know the
average reader who reads romance novels
reads five times more books than the
next genre book reader so there there's
voracious readers of romance if you like
that genre you like these books in fact
I know because my mom used to love
reading Danielle Steel she's got this
mansion here in San Francisco on
billionaires row that mansion was built
because people love to read romance you
know one of the most best-selling books
of all time Fifty Shades of Grey romance
fiction so you get the idea but most you
know entrepreneurs don't do this they
don't read this so they don't see this
opportunity but there's a multi-billion
dollar industry of romance novels and
there's a group of devoted readers and
they have time and money to spare so I
think you could deliver that same
content in a new way so well the new way
would be is like hooked so hook does
this app that's short form stories that
you read on your phone and they did it
for you know young adult fiction and
they raised fifteen million dollars they
have over 50 million readers I think you
could replicate that model you could do
hooked for romance novels and you could
build a very you can build a cash cow
you're gonna build an absolute cash cow
you can get people to pay you seven
bucks a month to subscribe for this
content to have unlimited
all-you-can-eat great romance stories
deliver to you on your phone so I think
there's a bigger opportunity here you
can pay a bunch of writers to write
writers are out-of-work writers need you
know who needs who needs a paycheck more
than an you know struggling author so
you can get a bunch of authors who are
capable and you can say hey I'll pay you
whatever hundred bucks per story
or whatever I don't know the rates but
basically you could get stories written
for fairly cheap and then they become
your content library that you are that
you're amassing and so I think there's a
big opportunity here but anyways ten
ideas for you from the podcast as you
can see we are idea machines if you're
listening to this it's because you can
become an idea machine too my goal is
for more people to see the world as you
know full of possibility when you see
something that's interesting you go and
want to learn more and you try to think
about how you can get involved and you
can make it bigger or when you see a
problem and you say wait why isn't there
an X that solves that problem and you
can come up with ideas to solve it
you're not gonna go and do all of these
but it's really great to train your
brain to see the world in this way most
people see the world as just the way it
is it's like this fixed thing and I see
it as this completely fluid thing full
of little holes where I can hook into
and I could build new things I encourage
you to do that don't look at the world
as this fixed thing and be surprised
every time someone invents something new
just see the world is full of needing
inventions and maybe you or somebody you
know could be the one who fills it all
right I'm out of here thank you for for
listening Sam we'll be back I think for
the next episode enjoy
[Music]